the number of u.s jobs has surged the
labor department said friday the nation
added 467
000 new positions in january higher than
many economists had predicted the
unemployment rate ticked up slightly to
4 percent up from 3.9 percent the month
before and the labor department revised
its job creation numbers for november
and december saying 709 000 jobs
were created here to tell us what it all
means cbs news senior business analyst
jill schlesinger jill good to see you
here great to be with you um the white
house was preparing everyone all week
that these numbers might be bad they
weren't tell us about them and why well
it was really important that economists
wanted to set the bar low because we had
no idea because these surveys are taken
in the first couple of weeks of every
month that could mean that well we're
going to see really weird numbers
because of the variant you know what
happened the labor market stomped
omicron this was like an unbelievably
better than expected as you said
467 000 jobs created you know i saw
estimates for 400 000 loss of jobs wow
and i think that was really great was
that there was broad-based hiring we
were worried that we would see leisure
and hospitality and bars and restaurants
really feel the brunt of us they added
151 000 jobs professional and business
services adding jobs retail adding jobs
so it was a very good report this report
also looked back to 2021 what what stuck
out most for you there i think that we
should never get too excited on the good
side and too worried on the downside so
we have these revisions they come out
once a year these benchmark revisions if
we look at last summer that's when we
thought oh we've got a couple million
jobs each month in june and july those
numbers were taken down but
consequently at the end of the year when
we were really worried i came on the air
i said oh my god they were weak reports
in november and december those were
revised up net net couple hundred
thousand jobs added for the total year
550 000 jobs on average every month it
was a wildly strong year we've also had
concern through the covid uh pandemic
that we were seeing a shrinkage in the
labor market what have we learned well
with these revisions we saw that the
labor force participation is higher than
we thought and in fact we're at a rate
that's just below where we were
pre-coveted we're not all the way there
but a lot of the shrinking of the labor
force has to do with retirements and
those were happening before covid and we
now know that there are a lot of people
who are over the age of 65 who said i'm
not going back in it's too dangerous
that's okay we do want to see the
younger people come back in the labor
force and that is starting to happen on
the other side of shrinkage is inflation
which has been a big concern for the
past year or more there's a new report
coming out this thursday what are you
expecting well we know that as of uh
december price is up seven percent from
a year ago and i don't think that that's
what that's a lot and i'm not sure it's
going to slow down it could be higher
than that i think we're going to see
high inflation for the next few months
now
the actual supply chain issues are
frankly starting to ease up just a touch
so the second half of the year should be
better but when you look at wages in
this jobs report being up 5.7 you've got
to sort of say to yourself but wait we
have inflation at seven percent higher
yeah so a lot of people are still
falling behind when we factor in prices
so just kind of like hold steady sounds
like no if you know if you are if you
are not getting a raise at your job go
look for another one because all the
evidence points to the fact that people
do get more money when they leave their
place of employment that said maybe you
go to your boss you want flexibility you
want some different hours that could be
important to you but i just want to be
clear this is a tight labor market
workers have leverage we need you guys
to all use that level all right great
point jill schlesinger thank you